I'm curious
um I first heard of a new Andre 3000
album when you spilled some beans that
you weren't supposed to spill Stone
man but when you when you revealed that
and then kind of walked it back at that
moment in time did you know it was a FL
a flute album I have no comment on any
of this I know if you want to Andre
3,000 verse there's an album called
Michael and it's on there song called
scientist and engineers and you should
listen to it have you um have you gotten
high to the to the Andre album because
it's a great album to relax to got high
too I got Stone well I'm Stone period
I'm stoned if I'm listening to Metallica
I'm stoned but I um I was curious to
hear it like everybody else and and and
I play and I smoke and I'm going to
probably eat some shrooms it's good
shroom
music I'm proud of um I'm proud of D and
big boy because they are out of a talent
program uh called Tri Cities high school
that also produced Escape that also
produced um KP one of the greatest ever
come y shouts out to KP KP the great DJ
as well it it just produced some amazing
artists and those guys like I tell you
about keeping that inner child alive big
boys kept it pushing and going giving us
new Styles variants whether it's fagr or
whatever whatever um new
I mean he helped us he's introduced so
many artists to us so many man I love
them and and with Dre Dre just being an
artist in that waiting until he's ready
to make art to make art and get people
interested um beyond what they thought
they were interested in I think is
amazing so I'm I'm very proud of him I'm
very proud of big you know cut Master
Swift their DJ did all the cuts on
Michael he's coming back in with us we
do make more music cuz he's an amazing
Trumpeter singer so we you know the
dungeon family lives Pat Ray and reek
still doing beats like I mean I gotta
beat I'm riding around right now so for
me man I'm just I'm proud that that for
whatever whatever compels you he's being
compelled to do
something yeah it's crazy because I just
had uh Victoria uh um Janelle Monet I
was GNA say Victoria mon Janelle Monet
um on the show and we were talking we
were talking about her uh her purple
ribbon run yeah cuz like a I don't think
a lot of people like kind of give
the proper respect to that like that
roster of artists big boy isn't big boy
is an amazing he's an amazing guy in
terms of picking talent and doing
business sometimes you're just a little
ahead of the curve yeah purple allst
stars was so good and it was like so
many names are on there like oh [__] oh
[__] rest in rest in peace to Nate super
Nate di of cancer L year rest in peace
to him shouts out to Black on C on Li BR
you know shouts out to sleepy brown you
know shouts out J buba shouts out Bubba
mhm yeah for sure man um for you man um
talk to me about like you know I know uh
the focus is Michael Y how
many times have you been in with LP in
the last like 12 months working on music
if if
any man we've been together cuz we were
touring we haven't worked on any I'm
talking about working on music you guys
had the Tour by the way I'm still very
mad that the rage tour never happened
for me to see with my own eyes man I I
wish you would have new yor
and and I'm glad Zack is healed up back
on the minut and congrats to all the
guys they got in introducted in the Rock
and Roll Hall Of rightfully so yeah the
way Runner Jews usually work is L tra
off into the W you know he TS off into
the Wilderness somewhere and probably
like kills bears and eats them and lives
as a wild man and then comes back with a
plethora of beat I feel like you'd be
the guy to kill bears and eat them no
I'm definitely down to kill [__] and eat
it usually we prefer killing deer and
hog where I'm from but just went hog
hunting with that Mexican OT we you had
fun down Texas you had we had a ball
right it was so much fun who dressed who
dressed them for you they already had
someone on site to dress the hall
cooking make sausages all that for you
well not cooking we just killed them and
left them no that's what we did no
you're not supposed to do that I swear
to God this out in Texas they're like
pest I don't know no but you're you're
supposed to [__] eat them it's a hog
you're not supposed to so we so we
killed a couple of them and then we came
back and like a pack of coyotes or
something all right that's what
destroyed them yeah that's good yeah I'm
just saying you're not so you know I
know they're like get so feral out there
but you kill I kill something I'm going
eat it like I'm sorry I'm not sports
fishing I'm not putting a [__] bass
Back That Bass get call the B getting at
that's my grandfather say I'm adding it
you know yeah no I mean I kind of felt I
mean because I've never been that's the
only time I ever been hunting you're
good though you should do that it was
fun everyone should do it at least you
know at least gets out once a year do
something we also were doing it out of a
helicopter yeah I've seen it I've seen
it um Kor shouts out to kinor who I
interview years he um he he he go I saw
I've seen him go out and lean out the
helicopter a video of himing I was
[__] spooked that [__] was dope yeah
hey we we're going on a hunting tangent
uh back to you and LP so LP he goes out
and he kills bears and does whatever he
and he comes back with a plethora of
Beats on a hard drive like like what do
you think and and what what I think is
usually oh [__] this is the [__]
album and like sequence and everything
damn near like oh my God this is it and
then from there it's right writing and
then we're just in there we're just in
there was vibing more than right we just
start playing [__] like he came out here
we were out here I forgot when it was it
might have been a year or might have
been just over but he came out we were
in different hotels but he came over um
to a spot I was at and he just played
something for me and he had part of
reverse on I said oh let me let me let
me get in there and um I went in there
man I spazz on that [__] like I'm like
oh [__] so you know to me I'm just like
I want to finish that one and whenever
we finish that one if he come we might
get rtj 5 I mean it's it's got to happen
one day that's something I cheer for but
again which're is you know it's it's
when it's going to happen like when it
happens but until it happens if you're
looking for a Dre verse Michael or if
you're looking for one half I got LP
verse I got both of them and it's like
and even the record with LP on the album
is like different for y'all got good
dope on the street that's all I'm
telling you man we still here for you
man you want to hear run the jewels you
need to listen to don't let the devil
it's a it's a no ID beat with a LP chop
different LP chopped it so yeah and taco
was on the drums on there right yep
little shomar who's who's one of the Run
jewes co-producers he was on there so
yeah man so I got the dope you do man
come get the dope man come run it up